ce qui est intéressant dans
l'intervention la d2 pro corrida c'est
qu'il parle toujours de leurs
perspectives ils ne voient pas souffrir
et certains même danis donc dit que s'il
voyait les animaux souffrir
à ce moment là le spectacle lui
déplairait et la question n'est pas est
ce que je vois la souffrance des
questions c'est un peu une réflexion
qu'il faut avoir c'est ce qu'il ya de la
souffrance derrière ce spectacle le fait
de ne pas avoir la souffrance ne veut
pas dire rien n'a pas et si on prend
l'analogie des boxeurs quand on regarde
un match de boxe
on peut ne pas voir de souffrances on
peut être aimé le spectacle de boxe et
on peut aimer le courage la ténacité où
l'agilité des des boxeurs il n'empêche
que les boxeurs quand même quand ils
reçoivent un certain nombre de coups
souffre sinon il ne le sait coulerait
pas sinon il ne gagnera pas un cas irait
la bataille vis-à-vis de l'autre donc je
pense qu'il faut dans ce débat et je
prends ça va revenir souvent il faut
arrêter de parler de celui qui regarde
uniquement quand il y à une interaction
entre un animal est un être humain ou
même que ce soit entre des êtres humains
il faut prendre les deux points de vue
et là le point de vue du taureau il n'a
pas du tout été évoquée
il est évident que plus vous rapporte
pour le taureau va pas être une partie
de plaisir comme ça de se faire
maltraiter par un sur dans une arène
donc je je pense que la partie on met le
taureau un petit peu au centre dans la
réflexion ou en tout cas un des éléments
de la réversion la corrida commence à
poser
[Musique]